the Frozen front lines in eastern
Ukraine nearly two years since Russia's
fullscale Invasion Ukraine is running
desperately short of weapons and keev is
now hoping Canada can provide a
Lifeline we are grateful Canada has been
assisting but we need more says
leftenant general Killa budanov in an
exclusive interview Ukraine's spy Chief
told global news they've asked Ottawa
for a donation
securely stored inside a warehouse at
this military Depot near Saskatoon are
more than 880,000
Rockets known as Canadian rocket vehicle
or CRV sens they were developed in
Winnipeg during the Cold War used to arm
Canadian and NATO war planes but our Air
Force no longer needs them the Rockets
were retired two decades ago and are now
slated to be destroyed Ukraine wants to
give these Cold War relics new purpose
Pur it's thousands enemy tanks that can
be destroyed this Ukrainian Special
Forces member and weapons expert whose
identity were concealing says they've
developed ground launchers capable of
firing the CRV SS he and his team have
offered to travel to Saskatchewan to
inspect the rockets and handle the
transport what the general situation in
Ukraine it's hard to find bullets and
shops Jeff we're asking for some
something that you don't
need something that you will never use
but several months since making the
request they're still waiting for an
answer the federal government has signed
a contract with a company to safely
dispose of the rockets and Canadian
officials also cited safety concerns in
a statement the defense minister said we
are pursuing testing to ensure that this
equipment is operationally effective and
safe to transport to Ukraine before any
potential donation several weapons
experts told global news that if stored
properly the CRV 7s should be functional
Canada you're in peace time you don't
get to tell Ukraine what is or isn't a
good risk this Canadian adviser to
Ukraine's military says if some of the
Rockets no longer work the ukrainians
can still make use of the
parts we need a lot of equipment the
general says in this case Canada can
save taxpayers money by transferring
this equipment to us we hope it will be
a
win-win each day Canada mols its
decision he says more ukrainians are
dying Jeff simple Global News Toronto